here's to honor among thieves we almost
pulled it off despite what everybody
thought
they're gonna blame us for the whole
thing where the patsies
don't forget mmm we're the bad guys
please don't make any sense
we won't wear the stories of Samson
leveling a temple with a single push for
the Philistine weapon of mass
destruction named Goliath the next war
will be fought with these metahumans
ours or theirs I want a simple task
force of the most dangerous made one
down y'all Joker's must be crazy this is
the deal you're going somewhere very bad
look at the three whites to do something
that gets killed you might want to work
on your team motivation thing you were
to Phil Jackson yeah he's like the gold
standard ok triangle [ __ ]
oh hey the farm lookie here oh yeah I
can't wait to show you my toys we're
going to the swirling ring of trash in
the sky they walk in the park
easy peasy don't make me shoot you
biggest boss then I've been in trillest
I'm a bigger problem when I
I've just begun man so when kids
kissing my vibe but she came back on my
chair
hey youtubers is Charlie new Suicide
Squad footage the movies coming out this
week so let's do a breakdown I also have
a reminder about the post-credits scene
at the end of this a lot of cool new
footage in this but I'm mostly going to
focus on the supernatural aspect of the
DC Universe like you know because a
Batman and Superman they're getting into
more New Gods territory well magic also
exists in the DC Universe so this magic
is actually pushing more into that
territory but kind of in a roundabout
way a very you know very supernatural
kind of magic so The Enchantress has had
a couple different backstory retcons in
the comics but essentially she is the
character June moon who looks like this
who is possessed by the spirit of a
witch I believe in the context of
Suicide Squad she's an archaeologist so
you see her rappelling down here this is
how she becomes possessed by the witch
but even though she fights with the
Suicide Squad like she's one of Amanda
Waller's first recruits like you see her
in the White House here so June moon
tries to use the powers of the
enchantress for good but several times
in the comics the big twist is is that
her evil enchantress persona takes over
at times like we see later in this
trailer here she goes full-blown
enchantress and becomes something of an
evil character so that's why a lot of
people were like oh she's probably gonna
be the villain of the movie but here's
where it really gets into supernatural
territory so if you've never read it
there's a big Suicide Squad story that a
lot of people think inspired the plot of
the movie called the nightshade Odyssey
now nightshade is another supernatural
character that's part of The Suicide
Squad but instead of being possessed by
an evil witch like another persona like
Enchantress's nightshade is actually
from another dimension
so trapped within this other dimension
is like this demonic figure called the
Incubus who's trying to make his way
back in and take over the normal
dimension so enchantress becomes a big
part of that story where it turns out
that instead of being possessed by the
normal enchantress spirit that everyone
thinks she's possessed by they secretly
learned that it's way worse than that in
the thing that is possessing enchantress
turns out to be much bigger so it sounds
like Suicide Squad is doing a very
Ghostbusters like twist you know like
with the Sigourney Weaver character how
she becomes possessed she's kind of a
villain of the movie for a period of
time but she's really being possessed by
this demonic figure that's serving
an even bigger demonic figure in this
character right here so based on some of
the language in the trailer like they
talk about the big floating ring of
trash in the sky that seems like a plane
to one of the dark dimensions in the DC
Universe hears that you're talking like
Trigon think like really big
supernatural demonic figures in the DC
Universe to make his way into our
dimension and the good enchantress
character the June moon character that's
a member of Suicide Squad kind of gets
roped into that and co-opted like she
gets taken over by this evil spirit so
make no mistake enchantress is not the
biggest villain in the movie even though
a lot of the marketing materials make
her seem that way I just I feel like
people are confused were they're
forgetting the plot of ghostbusters or
they didn't read the nightshade Odyssey
story in the comics that's actually a
really good story to read before you see
the movie if you really want to but just
like Batman V Superman didn't do any
comic book story specifically it was
inspired by a couple big Frank Miller
stories it's the same deal with Suicide
Squad so you don't have to read any of
the comics but I just cannot wait to see
them bring magic into the DC movie
universe like when Amanda Waller is
telling the story of David versus
Goliath this is the Goliath character
like the other half of that Incubus
succubus situation the real character
that's possessing enchantress like when
she goes full enchantress here but even
through characters like Diablo you get a
hint of how magic works in the DC
Universe like you see this face in the
flames just a little bit but you get the
idea like they're going really weird
with this and I totally love it most of
the powers that we've seen in the DC
Universe so far are still science-based
like metahumans like the flash for
instance so magic is just like the next
big barrier to break but let me know in
the comments like what's your favorite
part of this new footage and what do you
think is gonna happen with magic in the
DC Universe going forward even though I
don't think we're gonna see every single
character from Suicide Squad show up in
Justice League there'll be at least one
or two characters and what's happening
here in Midway City like a giant trash
circle in the sky is so big then of
course Bruce wayne/batman would be
talking about it when they're assembling
a team so while each different type of
movie has a different type of talk like
Suicide Squad movies will always be in
this kind of tone because it's a movie
about bad guys doing good things then
you have the Justice League movies which
have a slightly more positive spin
because you have a bunch of heroes
coming together or people learning to be
heroes so I just can't wait to see how
they sew it all together like there's
always connective tissue between all the
movies so in related news I have also
heard that there is a mid credit
sequence during Suicide Squad what that
means is is like you know when they have
the end credits like just the text
flowing through screen telling you who
did what in the movie there supposed to
be a scene right before that so make
sure you stay through the end of the
movie just in case but if you guys
didn't know there's a new round of the
DC giveaway that I just started all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video it's just
a $20 Amazon gift card so what's gonna
happen is is I was originally gonna do
Black Panther video so I'll just do that
next there might be a couple other
things that are dropping in the next
couple days too so a lot of exciting
stuff is Suicide Squad starts to come
out you start to see little things from
Justice League and the other DC movies
to where you guys wait for my next video
to post you can click here to learn all
about the ben affleck batman solo film
and you can click here to learn all
about Superman and Superboy on Supergirl
season 2 thank you so much for watching
everybody let's have five I'll see you
guys tonight